work that we've done over the last
couple of years the general theme is
doing important sampling in higher
dimensions and using hashing and in
order to do this so I want to give you
an overview of some of the results that
we've obtained to the flavor of some of
the techniques and all the various ways
in which all the various kinds of
problems we've applied them to some of
you might have seen some of these some
of this before in fact I've actually
spoken here at Simon's at least a couple
of times on two different things that
I'll actually talk about this talk so if
you feel like you've seen it before
you're probably right
but obviously something new in the top
view okay so let me start with a generic
problem and this will be the basis for
much of my talk okay so what's the
setting the setting is we given a bunch
of points in D dimensional space think
of D as very large there's some function
K will think we'll call it a kernel
function it takes a pair of points now
it puts a number positive quantity and
we have query point Q what we like to do
is we'd like to go over the data set
compute this pairwise function k PQ for
the query Q and all the points in there
is that sum them up and average over the
de-icer okay so you know given this data
that it's easy to compute this linear
time just make a pass of the data the
main question is if you wanted to
evaluate this anymore evaluate this not
for one query but for multiple queries
is there some way in which we could
pre-process the data set so as to be
able to answer this question quickly
okay query time what kind of data
structure would be need in order to pre
process this data so as to answer such
query speed so that's going to be the
basic question I'm not going to spend
very much time on motivating the problem
just say briefly that you know this this
kind of question for example arises in
nonparametric statistics where you have
a dataset it comes from some unknown
distribution you'd like to figure out
what this distribution is this is one
class of nonparametric method that's
used to figure out what the distribution
is if you if you think about this kernel
function for example one kind of kernel
function that people use is the Gaussian
function this amounts to saying that
let's take the empirical distribution
let's smear it a little bit and let's
compute the average of this snare
distribution okay so so people care
about this kind of calculation and in in
this setting but also a number of other
settings okay so this is the basic it's
a question so there are a few different
questions you could ask one is this data
structure problem that I just mentioned
if you wanted to approximate this
quantity let's say this average is mu
can you approximate this to within 1
plus minus epsilon and how you do it how
what's the data structure okay there's
also this another problem that people
are considered which is sort of this
batch offline problem you're given a
bunch of points P and Q beforehand
imagine building this kernel matrix K IJ
with which has the kernel values for P I
and Q J VJ and now given a vector W
you'd like to approximate the product of
K times W there's another problem the
people people care about yet another
problem might be you want to sum up the
all of the entries of this kernel matrix
an average over all the points how
quickly can you do this
so I'll mostly focus on this on this
rest of the problem ok
all right so you know one question is
what what is this current function and
I'll tell you give you examples of
kernel functions people use one commonly
use kernel function is the Gaussian
function there's also the exponential
function you can look at functions which
look like exponential in inner products
and you can put different kinds of
functions over here in the in the
exponent all functions of the inner
product there are other functions or
logistic function there are also a bunch
of functions here these are all
functions that people took care of our
news and as been see actually the how
hard this problem is the the resources
that we need to evaluate this will
actually depend on the kernel function
okay so one theme in the talk will be
that we can do better if we know
something about the kernel of this
kernel function that we care about so
let me tell you a few results that are
known for these kinds of problems
so before I state the results let's do
some normalization okay so I said let me
have this kernel function and we want to
average this kind of function over all
the values of the tip over over all the
data points
I just normalized so all our kernel
function values are between 0 and 1 okay
and let's let mu be the average mu is
the squatty electronic computer so one
natural approach is to just do random
sampling okay it's sort of actually
summing up all the data set if we just
random sample is that how many samples
you need to get a 1 plus epsilon
approximation it's very easy to
calculate the number of samples that you
need first of all the dependence on
epsilon is 1 over epsilon squared ok and
the dependence on mu is going to be 1
over mu ok so 1 over mu dependence is
pretty easy to see the hard case is
where you're getting new contribution
because exactly new fraction radar gives
you one and the rest
zero so even if a random sample to even
hit something and gives you a nonzero
contribution to sample one over here
type an example needs so much is that it
these kinds of questions have been
studied in lower dimensions by
GREENGUARD and strain bringer and
collaborators these there's something
called the fast Gauss transform that
allows you to compute this kind of
quantity for for all pairs and if you
use those methods the scaling is
exponential in dimension okay so on one
hand the dependence is logarithmic in
one of them you okay but unfortunately
these methods behave very badly as the
dimensional view their exponential in
the dimension and very roughly speaking
these methods are based on hierarchical
spaced partitions and doing something
clever with these with the distribution
with respective hierarchal space
partitions we're importing a scale very
badly with it so the first method you
mentioned does not require before system
that I guess the first one doesn't
require providers yeah yeah so it's it's
very attractive yeah so technically this
right this is trying to compute the
following quantity it's you have
endpoints computing for each of these
endpoints the net effect of the
remainder of an intercept on that point
so you're not actually doing any
pre-processing you can do all of this at
query time it's just that if you have a
batch of n queries at the same time you
won't you want to evaluate all over
that's the way in which these things are
phrased
although the that we have explained this
out sort of said this is the sort of the
the work per point here
alright there are a bunch of results by
Jeff Phillips and his collaborators that
give very interesting guarantees they
get additive epsilon approximations the
guarantees are sort of stronger because
they're also this sort of for all versus
for each guarantees and these guarantees
hold for all queries simultaneously and
what they get is very interesting
dependence they basically say that you
can get a core set of this size so you
can get an additive epsilon
approximation and in our language if you
want to get a multiple of 1 plus epsilon
approximation the dependence would be so
much ok so again the the dependence on
mu is one of them you so one of the
results one of the main results I want
to tell you about is by using hashing by
using estimators that are based on
hashing we can actually improve the
dependence on mu from 1 over mu 2 1 over
square root I'm gonna tell you about
that this was obtained in a paper of
mine with Paris Americas who's here in
the audience and we managed to do this
for some of the kernels that I mentioned
about the Gaussian kernel the
exponential kernel and the TSP on some
time explaining how how this works is
gonna be the basis for everything I say
later in later work we also managed to
generalize these ideas to pairwise
functions which look like exponential in
some function of the inner product ok ok
and roughly speaking we get the same
kind of dependence now this is where my
sound dependence on what this function
fee is okay I'll tell you a little bit
about that as well and finally I want to
talk about whether we actually do need
this polynomial dependence and mu so all
of these results are going to have the
parents of mu which is 1 over square
root mu which means that when mu is
really tiny the query time is very large
do we actually need this dependence on
you could we get something which has a
better venue and I'll answer this
question in the latter half of the talk
because I want to avoid this exponential
dependence on D so not only do I want to
okay so I want to not get a polynomial
dependence on Miu without having to pay
this exponential cost that's the
question other questions is it possible
to combine the hashing base estimator
with the fast Gauss transform in the
lower dimension I don't know actually in
distinguish and I don't know whose
possible
but what sort of approximation guarantee
you get in terms of epsilon so all of
these are trying to get a 1 plus epsilon
approximation that was the approximation
1 plus Epsilon okay all right so let me
tell you I start building up the
sequence of ideas by starting with this
work I'll talk a little bit about about
this work and then finally I'll talk
about how one can break this polynomial
dependence on mu if you know some
additional information about your
corners so so this was the paper where
we started working about and eve's on
these ideas in Fox 2070 ok so here's the
problem that we're gonna solve actually
this is not exactly the problem I I
phrase but if you can solve this problem
then you can solve the problem of
estimating kernel density within 1 plus
Epsilon so let's say you just wanted to
distinguish between two cases either the
kernel density is less than 1 minus
epsilon times Mew or it's bigger than 1
plus epsilon times if you had a
procedure to do this then you can do
binary search and figure out what you
can get a good approximation to what the
kernel density this is our problem
one other technical thing we're gonna
say that are very interested in solving
this problem so long as the kernel
density is within the range tau 2 1 so
pre-pro we're gonna assume that our
kernel density is in this range in our
data structure will be built around tau
tau will be parameter to a desktop ok so
if you want to solve this problem we can
do this with query time which is 1 over
root mu now I'm gonna ignore this but
whenever I have this kind of credit I'm
always gonna have 1 over epsilon squared
dependence but I'm not mention it so I'm
gonna get query time which is 1 over
square root nu and the size of the data
structure is going to be n times 1 over
square root top ok now if you remember
was this lower bound
that's the main result all right okay
and we do this for as I said the
Gaussian kernel for the exponential
kernel and also for this kernel that's
called the generalized D student curve
so this as I said before random sampling
needs quai time 1 over mu this gives you
a square root new improvement over
random sampling of course if a huge cost
which is random sampling is very easy we
need no pre-processing this one on the
other hand you do need to do some few
processing before hand ok so one thing
that might be a little strange about
this result is that mu is the quantity
that we're trying to estimate but I'm
expressing my query time as a function
of mu which is exactly this quantity go
try and estimate actually what's going
to happen is that our algorithm is going
to adaptively estimate me exactly by
doing this by n research like procedure
ok so when it terminates the guarantee
is that the amount of time that it takes
is 1 over square root all right so let
me explain the main idea behind this
this first piece of work let's try to
think about a more simple setting ok so
you have your data set consisting of
points X I there's a weight attached to
every element of the data set right it's
the weight is just the kernel value
right the governor value between X and X
I and what we want to do is approximate
the sum or the average of these colors
values in other words we want to
approximate the sum of these W eyes
now what is random sampling do random
sampling picks a random element amongst
these and and uses the averages a bunch
of these random values okay now that the
problem is that why it is random
sampling too badly
the the case where atom sampling as
badly is exactly where a small number of
weights have very large contribution
okay if you could sort of sample in a in
a more intelligent way so you can do
well in the setting where a small number
of points a very large contribution then
it could be random sampling and that's
the main idea okay
in our case what is this what is this
quantity that were trying to estimate we
don't I submit a sum of the kernel
values which are the kernel values that
are likely to be large well there are
exactly the points that are near the
query okay so intuitively if we could
build a sampler with samples points or
any other query with higher probability
then points are further away we should
be able to do better right and that's
exactly what we do okay so I mean I
agree about important sampling suppose
instead of uniform sampling we had a
bias sample okay so we had some black
box way of sampling rate aside so that I
is returned with probability Q of I now
it's possible to just like with random
sampling is possible to design an
unbiased estimator for this while
sampling procedure what we do is we
sample element I and then we look at the
weight WI divided by the probability
that you saw another element Qi you know
this is an unbiased estimator here's the
standard in importance sampling the
variance of this estimator is going to
be summation of WI squared by Qi now you
could ask what is the how should you set
your sampling probabilities so as to get
a low variance estimator
well the best choice the ideal choice of
sampling probabilities is to sample
elements
directly proportional to their weights
so that this will actually minimize the
variance here's a challenge in our
setting the weights are these kernel
values okay we don't know them a priori
and besides not only do we not know them
they priori they're not fixed for the
data set take query dependent queries in
a particular region you gonna gonna have
to you want to prove you prefer to
sample points or in that region if the
queries another region you prefer to
point sample to sample points in another
region and so on okay so somehow we have
a designer sampler which is inherently
very dependent that's exactly what
locality-sensitive hashing does for us
what is the colony sampling I think
intuitively it's a way to randomly
partition the data in such a way that
points are nearby I like you to fall
under the same piece of the partition
and point sort of further further away
unreal to be unlikely to fall in the
same part of the partition okay so this
is a very influential technique to build
what I call nearest neighbors our data
structures how does this technique work
well you typically have some family of
hash functions so given a point this
computes a value there's a distribution
of these hash functions now there's also
a collision probability so given points
x and y you can look at the probability
that x and y land up in the same bucket
if you pick the random hash function
from this one and typically this
collision probability x and y is going
to be some function of the distance
between x and y okay you expect that
points are nearby are more likely to
collide line in same hash pocket than
points are further away you can actually
characterize this for a particular
family of hash functions there's a nice
there's a function that tells you
exactly what how the collision probably
behaves as a function of the distance
right so that's what the Carlie Anthony
bashing gives us and the key idea as I
said is to think of locality-sensitive
hashing as a way to implement important
sampling for others so how does this
actually work
what we're gonna do is we're gonna pick
a family of hash functions with some
collision probability okay we're gonna
evaluate these hash functions H 1 to H
em on our data set okay and now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna look at
the query write say the queries X we're
gonna look at all the points of the data
set that have the same hash values
equate it land up in the same hash
bucket of the query from amongst these
points we're going to sample a random
point so we value the hash function on
the data side together the hash function
on the query look at everybody who has
who collides with the query and sample a
random element the evaluation on the air
that is done a priority is
pre-processing so we have a hash table
everything is already placed into a hash
table the query maps to the hash table
and now we just look at another right so
even though a class like that
the much of this is done as part of it
okay
adolescence when you when you just
sample one is that like for the speed of
birth how does it compare to just doing
evaluating everything everything is in
bucket so one thing is that I don't have
a handle over how many elements falling
on the same bucket okay it could be that
you know a lot of there is that one same
bucket and I might spend a lot of time
so for efficiency reasons I'm going to
look at only one element it would
simplify the the calculations a little
bit if I could if I could actually look
at the entire bucket and look at its
contribution but I'm actually I'm going
to look at only one element yeah so
you're guaranteed to have something in
the same bucket I guaranteed no and if
you if you don't get something then you
return zero so if you if you have
something in the same in the bucket then
you look at the value of the kernel
right
I remember the sound important sampling
you got to take the value that you get
divided by the probability of having
sampled a settlement okay so what's the
probably of having sample settlement two
things need to happen one is this
element needs to land in the same hash
bucket as the query
well that's given by this probability
but then of the many elements that
landed up in the same bucket as this
query this particular element better be
picked so that probability is divided by
the size of the hash bucket
so this is the value of our estimator
it's it's it's exactly what important
sampling gives you right except this is
some sort of weird important sampling
because it's based on this hash table
there's a is a this weird dependency
between these these probabilities that's
introduced by this hash table okay so
this is an unbiased estimator not very
hard to show and the main technical
contribution is really analyzing this
bonding the variance of this okay so
earlier I told you what what's the
variance for importance of it was just
some of the weights square divided by
the probabilities
in this case it turns out that the
variance of this estimator is exactly
the same thing but then there's this
pesky term here and this pesky term says
it's the expected size of the hash
bucket containing the query given that I
map to this particular hash buggy I is
the okay so you have the IT data point P
I is the probability that the I the data
point mapped to the same hash bucket as
the query
it seems like a really unwieldy thing to
hand lives it sometimes it depends on
the hash function and some weird way it
depends on the structure of the data set
in some way right because how do you
talk about sizes of hash buckets and so
on one of the key ideas and simplifying
this analysis is that in some sense the
worst case data says the what the data
sets that maximize the variance are
those that have their support only on
two points so somehow run through the
query all the data sets it's either at
one distance threshold or another
distance ratio okay those are exactly
the data sets that give you the the
worst value from this variance
once you have this insider really make
Genesis much simpler okay so this
quantity here that let me tell you what
was actually involved in the analysis I
won't give you the analysis but tell you
what what are the key facts are you this
thing the expected size of the hash
bucket is just the sum of the collision
probabilities right what's the
probability that I and J both belong to
the hash bucket divided by P R that's
what this is then the only other thing
that we use in the analysis is that the
probability that both I and J belongs
hash bucket is at most the minimum of P
I and PJ this is a very simple naive
bond but that's really all we use in you
know so using these facts you can
actually show that these the only facts
that you use you can show that this
expression is maximized for data sets
that have a very simple data simple
structure they have their support on
only two different distances
okay so now analysis one thing that that
gives you interesting bounds is to look
for hash functions where the collision
probability scales somehow is a function
of this kernel that you wanted right as
you expect earlier we said if you wanted
to do important sampling the probability
of sampling an element should be
directly proportional to its weight
right if you use that intuition it would
seem the natural thing to do we to find
a hash function whose corrosion probably
was exactly equal to the kernel value
okay so that's not quite the case the
fact that this this this is not pure
important sampling a sampling based on a
hash function and the hash bucket and so
on so forth things are a little more
complicated it's still useful to think
about a hash function whose collision
probably somehow behaves somehow is
controlled by the kernel behaves like
the kernel in some sense okay so we look
for a hash function whose collision
probability behaves like the kernel
raised to the power of beta is the issue
that they may not exist in either search
with beta equals 1 or is it the case
that you actually prefer beta not to be
one we actually has the ladder
we prefer beta an article one okay
Hajduk was one is not is not the optimal
choice yes what happens so it turns out
that if you compute the variance of so
if you try to find a hash function whose
collision probably behaves like the
kernel value raised to the power of beta
okay as I said the worst case is this
two point dataset where all the points
are either at one distance residues from
zero or another distance less additions
so much where the Confucians mean turns
out that the best value of beta is half
so so I won't actually go through the
analysis but turns out that in our
analysis that the best choice for
collision probability is proportional to
the kernel value raised to the power of
half okay
and we can actually achieve this for all
of these kernels that I mentioned before
for the Gaussian kernel for the
exponential kernel and for the T student
kernel we can actually achieve this and
this is why using standard LSH function
so so for the Gaussian we use an the
cardi sensitive hash function due to
endow nyan in dec something called the
ball carving the hash function for these
views another one which was done earlier
for Euclidean yourself all right so good
what is the main insight main insight
was that if you know some if you have a
kernel function you can find a locality
sensitive hashing function which somehow
match is the collision probably somehow
matches the kernel then you get this 1
over square root 0 all right questions
and we can do this for these for these
particular kernel values which are you
know interesting kernels are people do
care about yes functions one random
sampling is actually
how do they look like such an important
chance what a cleaner functions where
random zomlings optima doctor and i this
result right for example in some cases
that the best thing you can do is either
two random some blank or for example the
best thing you can do is either search
oh I see other situations where LSH
actually doesn't help so as we'll see
later in some sense the how steep your
coordinates
okay is a very important factor in some
sense the Gaussian is very steep but you
could people think of going to value
even steeper than that so definitely the
structure of the the structure of this
kernel function does affect whether or
not LSD is going to be useful at all at
some point you don't have local
Alexandra wash functions are able to
distinguish between near and far points
to the fidelity that you need yes that
definitely there are you could you could
construct kernels where random sampling
is maybe the best
maybe I don't think about that
intuitively it seems like should be
possible
yes you've listed em you did list better
so somehow you do and I'm guessing no
matter you're gonna pay respect or I
mean like over something or something
but you don't care that paydays use it
for something is always like I fix I
think is better to be half M is the MS
or this hidden factor which I didn't
mention in this result does affect the
running time yeah but I've hidden it in
the previous expression sir all right
Amelia but another piece yes as a quick
question about the karna estimation so
usually they say kernel density
estimation the kernel is not really
fixed right in some sense because you
want you want to do model selection you
want to choose the bandwidth of the
kernel in essence a Gaussian kernel you
want to choose the bandwidth of it
and so would that mean here that we
didn't
selection framework that you need to
come up with a different hash function
for every particular or could you build
a single data structure that you see the
question yeah yeah see so okay this is
this is a point that I didn't really
address in this talk but we are what
comes in at the point where you fix the
kernel where you've done your moral
selection already and now you apply our
data structure so if you were actually
going to not commit to the kernel but
you might pick from a variety of kernels
then you would actually need to design
different data structures for different
possible choices of the car certainly
one one drawback of this approach I will
say and maybe I'll comment on this later
for some of the other work that I have
mentioned yeah you're the bad cases
where the it has a very specific like to
point kind of home if you have the
promise that the data is not right you
can actually get some improve results
yeah so if you if you make some
assumptions the data pseudo-random in
some sense not all of it is concentrated
in a small region roughly speaking and
you quantify that in some way then you
can tie that into the analysis and and
get some improvement
alright let me tell you about another
piece of work with its Paris similar
case on what's called partition function
estimation okay so it's a very similar
problem slightly different let me tell
you what the what the problem is again
you're given a bunch of points you're
given a function Phi that takes inner
products and maps them to a real number
you have a query Y which is also a unit
vector okay and now what we like to do
is we like to take the square dy and
again sum up some pairwise function
summed over the entire dataset but in
this case this pair wise function is
exponential in some function of the
inner product what we like to do this is
called the partition function it's very
interesting function it arises in a
number of different settings people care
about evaluating this quickly will ask
the same question can you design a data
structure to pre-process the data set so
as to compute this
to approximate this efficient all right
okay so I mean let me say one thing
about this before I start well let's
let's say that all of our results are
gonna be parametrized by how this
function fee behaves okay and the one
thing that we need about this function
fee is the Lipschitz constant okay how
fast this function PJ let's say L of Phi
is the Lipschitz constant since this
function fee is applied to inner
products inner products range between 1
and minus 1 these are unit vectors we
know that the maximum the difference
between the maximum value value that
most twice the Lipschitz constant so we
can normalize and make sure that all of
the functions that we want the kernel
values are all in this range e to the
power of minus 2 L of Phi and 1 by just
by scaling okay so let's say we're in
that setting now what we could do is if
a data set is very large because all of
our values are in this range you could
actually just random sample the data set
and just pretend that we couldn't
compute everything on this random sample
so what what I'm trying to say is that
the effective end effective size of the
data set is actually e to the power of
twice the Lipschitz constant if a
dataset was much larger than that we
could always sample down and bring it
down to this size so whenever I express
my results as a function of L of V if
you want to express them in terms of n
what you should do is you should take n
to be e to the power of twice the
Lipschitz constant and similarly mu
which is the average of this quantity is
some number between 1 over N and 1 okay
all right so we'll we'll do this
reduction beforehand okay so here's the
here's the result maybe you should think
of this result as as an extension of the
previous results
to a more general class of functions so
for any convex function Phi you can
design a data structure where the query
time is proportional to 1 over square
root mu and there's some dependence on
this function Phi now this dependence
function Phi is a little ugly I've sort
of tried to hide it there is this
dependence here on the query time and
there is this dependence here on the
pre-processing time my the reason I want
to talk about this is mostly to
highlight the techniques I think so the
techniques more interesting than precise
result itself it just says that these
hashing based ideas can be applied more
generally to more general class of
functions ok it's not clear that this
kind of dependence and s be the best
possible but it's one of the techniques
that I want to highlight more than ok I
should say one more thing which is the
the results on using locally sensitive
hashing as a way to compute these
estimates was actually independently
done by spring and srivasa and untrue
Mali is here in the audience and they
actually they were motivated by
estimating exactly this kind of
partition function ok so they were
trying to estimate this partition
function they realize that ah hi it'd be
nice to get some sort of important
sampling based estimator and they used
exactly the casual sensitive hashing
okay so one you could say you know what
what improvement do you get over random
sampling roughly speaking if you use
this translation that n is e to the two
of lfi and nu is 1 over n for random
sampling you need space order of and
query time order of n in our LSH ways
estimator you need space n to the three
halves because you have a bunch of hash
tables but the query time becomes square
root n get a square root and improvement
in let me tell you what's new in this
very data structure relative to what
you've seen before so earlier we had one
hash one family of hash functions and we
built our hash tables using this one
family bash functions in this we're
going to do something slightly different
we're going to have a T different
families of hash functions H 1 to H T ok
each of them is going to have their own
collision probabilities okay and some
sense different hash families are going
to be tailored to different portions of
the inner product space so different
hash families are designed to have the
collision probability speak for
different values of inner products ok so
so far when we talked about locality
sensitive hashing I've talked about you
know implicitly you you think about
locality sensitive hashing where points
that are nearby are more likely to hire
on to the query bucket 10.0 far away
right points are close are more likely
to collide that point to the far away
it's actually possible to tweak the idea
of locality sensitive hashing a little
bit I come up with this notion of
distance sensitive hashing well points
that are at a certain distance rather
than points that are close by points at
a certain distance are more likely to
collide than other points
going at a stage to the new distance
function it's not quite as
straightforward as that I don't know how
to do it in that way okay but but what
this does is that if you look at the
collision probability you would assume
that this is a monotone decreasing
function right this in this case the
collision probability is something that
increases and then decreases and Peaks
exactly at some some desired point in
their inner product space
so we're going to choose a bunch of
these different hash families and each
of them is designed to peak at a
different point in our inner product
space each of these is going to have
their own volition probably in this way
now we actually want to compute the this
dysfunction which is e to the power of
some Phi times inner product we're going
to take this this quantity and we're
going to break it up over our p hash
functions and the th hash function is
going to be responsible to this one
piece so this is the quantity that we
want to sum up this is the quantity that
we want to sum over the data set
we're going to break this up over our T
hash functions and the teeth hash
function is going to be responsible to
sum up this quantity over the entire
dataset right
so I didn't tell you what this WT is
I'll tell you how we get this WT I'll
sort of indicate that but I won't give
you my exercise so right now let's just
leave it as a beauty will actually fix
this favour okay
all right so in order to do this we're
going to do exactly what we did before
we're gonna sample hash functions from
each of these families create these hash
tables you know pre-process the data set
in this way and then when when the query
comes along we're gonna also subject it
to all of these hash functions look at
the query hash buckets look at where
that query hash is on to and now you
know earlier our hash function was
exactly this quantity right we didn't
actually sum up of the data over all of
our t hash hash families now we're gonna
sum this up over all our Teatre
and the teeth hash family is remember
trying to compute the sum of these WT so
each one has their own weight function
that the tracker okay um so this seems
like a horribly complicated scheme right
there are too many moving parts you have
these different hash families then you
have this complex estimator the main
challenge is how do you go about trying
to get some grip on time to analyze this
right the main thing is trying to bound
the variance of this overall estimator
okay so maybe I'll give you a flavor of
how it's done right of a sort of a
cartoon version of how it's done rather
than really giving any any details so
you know the main idea is that look
earlier we said the key idea before was
designing one hash family says that the
collision probability was proportional
to square root of the corner value okay
this is actually a very hard thing to do
in general I mean if you think if you
give me an arbitrary function e to the
power of Phi in a pair of x and y I
don't know how to do this okay in fact I
could do this exactly for this Gaussian
exponential then perform your families I
don't know how to do this for other ones
and so that's why we do this more
complicated but more flexible scheme
which has the ability to handle way more
functions yeah so as I said we have this
let's say is the function we are trying
to estimate your gonna we're gonna break
it up into a bunch of segments have a
different hash function responsible for
each segment okay and sum up exactly
this segment okay so the teeth hash
function is going to be responsible for
this segment that's that's the picture
that you should have in mind it's not
quite as clean actually the this dthe
hash function will be responsible for
not just this segment but something
fairly wider than that
okay all right so the main challenge is
to figure out how do we decompose our
our function of interest into a bunch of
different functions right how do we
compute these WT exactly the question
that Jerome was asking okay so we're
gonna pick our hash families from these
distant sensitive hash functions that I
mentioned before okay
now based on these collision properties
we're gonna figure out what these
weights should be so our goal is to
identify what these different hash
families are each comes with their own
collision probabilities and then you
need to figure out for this particular
hash family what is the function that
it's actually computing okay and then
this is this is the final estimator okay
so the key idea and this is the key idea
behind analysis is if we set our so this
is the function that we're trying to
compute we want to figure out what
portion of this function should be
allocated to that t earth hash family
okay turns out that if we allocate to
the teeth hash family this portion of
this function so what do I mean by this
portion of this function
the portion that's allocated teeth hash
family is proportional to the square of
the collision probability for the teeth
hash family so if we make this choice it
turns out that this very nice
simplification that happens in the
analysis okay the variance of this
seemingly complicated scheme is somehow
bounded by the variance of a much
simpler scheme effectively we can think
of this as a simple hash function one
hash function whose collision
probability is the max of each collision
probability and this is a key
simplification in Hindi analysis like
much easier so now a goal is to find
design these hash family such that the
maximum of the collision probability
will behaves like square root of this
particular function this is a much
easier goal this is exactly what we do
okay I'll spare you much of the details
now let me tell you about very quickly
tell you about some of the other things
I want to touch on so this is what they
appeared false 2018 with artists backers
and peer trendek and parents and this
brings me back to this question that I
mentioned before which is you know is
this polynomial dependence on MU
necessary so there is actually there are
actually lower bounds that are not
exactly for the problems we care about
but very similar problems that suggest
that if your kernel is steep if your
kernel actually varies very rapidly okay
and and the Gaussian for example falls
off very rapidly then some sort of
polynomial depends on you seems
necessary so if you want to get around
this polynomial dependence on MU you
need some additional information about
the kernel so in particular these
kernels it seemed very difficult
although we don't have a precise
bail-bond for our query problem
it seems difficult it is inconceivable
that it's not possible to do this for
these kinds of carbons they're a bunch
of other kernels that have polynomial
dependence on distance they vary more
gracefully they don't fall off as deeply
and so these there's some hope that you
might actually have you might actually
be able to get rid of this polynomial
dependence on you your result where the
query time is independent of means for
behaves more and more gracefully with me
okay and that's the main result the main
result is that this fast decay of kernel
value is really the only obstruction to
efficient algorithms okay so if you had
a corner which decay is more gracefully
then in fact you can get a better of
okay and for this we actually
parameterize the current we say okay so
we say the kernel is smooth if the
following thing happens if you look at
the kernel value relative to X look at
the point Z and look at a point y look
at the ratio of their kernel values okay
kernel value of XZ and XY look at the
ratio if this depends on the ratio of
distance is raised to the power of T
okay let me see that this kernel is Lt
smooth so if gonna basically if you
think about the kernel value as
depending polynomially as a function of
distance is raised to the power of T
then we think of this function as smooth
okay for a small value of T the point is
if your function is of this time then
you can actually get a good result
what's the result says that if you have
this problem when you have such a smooth
corner okay then you can do this in
query time that depends essentially on
two to the power of this
see divided by epsilon squared and the
storage space is also to the power of T
times n okay so somehow this if you know
that you're going on a smooth inning
actually get a pattern okay so how does
this work
I'll tell you the main idea but maybe it
will be hard to express much more in
five minutes okay so suppose you have
let's go back to this idea that you had
a bunch of weights you want to sum up
their values Thanks earlier we said that
if you wanted some of these values you
can just sample one element right and
look at the average now if the if these
values are all in a small range if the
ratio of the maximum to the minimum
value is small and you don't need a
sample that many to get a good idea
about the averages the main idea is to
take your data set right and somehow
partition them into pieces says that in
each piece you have a bound on the ratio
of the maximum to the minimum okay so
take your data set partition into pieces
so they're in each piece there is a
bound the ratio of maximum to minimum
and now you can just go over all your
pieces and in each piece you won't have
a sample very much to figure out what
the contribution of that piece is that's
main idea yeah and so the number of
pieces exponential LT the number of
pieces exponential NT okay what's the
challenge in doing this the challenge in
doing this is that again these values of
query dependent this partition of the
data set has to be somehow berry
dependence not fixed but some are very
dependent okay my name is the point is
we can handle all of this stuff and we
can actually design a data structure
which a query time allows us to design
to produce a partition in the data set
where in each piece of a partition the
ratio of the kernel values is small and
that's how it works okay I won't say
very much about what this analysis it
depends on a certain quantity called the
average condition number but I think at
this point will be very hard to it's in
the amount of time I'm not sure I
explained what what that party
okay
in the last few minutes let me tell you
about yet another piece of work where we
used this idea of locality sensitive
hashing as an important sampling
facilitator and this is a work by with
caribou and Vishnu nacho and this
appeared at ICM out 2018 this is a
slightly more practical paper
tell you about the the problem I'll tell
you what is different about what we did
here relative to the other things have
you seen that's the main thing I want to
convey okay so this was motivated by
trying to design algorithms for what a
core word embedding so some of you might
have heard about this thing you have
large corpus of text you take every word
in this corpus and associate it with a
high dimensional vector okay let me ask
the question given such a collection of
vectors let's say they all normalize
other unit vectors given a query vector
can we tell how dense the region around
the square e vector is very simple
question okay so given up given this
high dimension data set given a query
vector can we estimate how many points
are in nearby region around the square e
vector okay and what is nearby I mean
that's a nearby 60 degrees
let's just fix it to be 60 degrees for
this so you know what just to just to
set the context one particular data set
that we were interested in is what's
called this love data set it consists of
about two million three hundred
dimensional word vectors okay and I said
the the range of interest is zero to
sixty degrees now in this data said most
vectors are orthogonal right so as you
might expect if you just pick the random
vectors with the three and dimensional
you would expect most most pairs of
vectors we are talking in the 0 to 60
degree and you do get interesting
related things so for example if you try
Venice you get things like Florence and
Naples and Rome the only 12 other word
vectors which are in the 0 to 60 degree
range for what like cake you get short
cake batter tiramisu there are about 117
such word vectors for a book there are
about 4 and 24 such word vectors point
is typically there are very very few
in your data set that nada within 68
reason they're quite correlated okay so
what we want to know is how dense is
this region given a query vector how
many points are within 60 degrees of the
query bit okay so as you might expect we
applied this locality sensitive hashing
base technique the natural LSH theory
uses is random hyperplane base LSH slice
the space where random have you playing
assign one bit based on which side I
playing you follow right we are about
two million there data points we use 20
bit hash addresses which means on
average you expect about two points to
fall into hash focus okay what's the
problem if you apply a vanilla LSH right
in order estimate how many things that
was in 60 degrees you need a lot of hash
tables and the main point is that look
at two vectors that are 60 degrees from
each other
apply 20 different hash functions what's
the probability that they fall into the
same hash pocket what is the problem
that they fall in the same side of these
20 different hyperplane it's very very
small okay so in order to even see
something of interest in the zero range
you would need a lot of different hash
tables and that's a big problem okay so
we modified this scheme and this is the
key innovation in this paper we said
instead of sampling from the hash bucket
that the query falls into we sample from
all the hash buckets that are within a
certain Hamming radius of this place
okay isn't this like multi probe hashing
or multi-purpose it it is it is related
yes it is related so in multi probe LSH
what happens is in addition to the query
bucket you also prove a bunch of other
buckets that you think are likely to
contain things already nearby very
similar idea okay
there are some issues with using exactly
that which is why we we did this okay so
we sample from everything within a
Hamming distance D from the query pocket
okay one key one key
meant is that you know in all of the
previous schemes that I described you
basically pick one sample per hash
bucket and so in some sense the Indian
Alice's you need this otherwise the
dependencies that you can't control and
can't get rid of here we did actually
try to get it was very important for us
to get multiple samples per hash table
we want to control the detecting all
things so okay how do we sample right
that's the question you don't want to
actually examine all the buckets in this
particular having radius okay so once so
imagine you have this 20 bit hash table
right which has two rows at 20 entries
you know the query falls in one bucket I
want to pick a random element from
amongst all buckets that are within
having radius 5 of this how do I do that
I don't want to go over all the 20
choose 5 different having buckets know
that you can actually pre-process okay
so you can pre-process the rate the this
hash table to have some additional
information that allows you to random
sample
okay so this is slightly sadder point
but you can you can work this out it's
not very hard how do you imagine like
estimate the number where they spawn do
you know something that you mentioned
right you get a sample okay so what do
you do your goal was to do something
okay good so use it the same Impa the
important sampling machinery right so
given an element first of all if it's
not within the 0-60 range it counts as
zero if it's within the 0-60 range it
has a weight of one but divided by the
probability that you would have seen
this element in the range of X and now
you average this okay all right so there
are I am over time I should I should
stop this is my last leg there are there
are there are two sources of error okay
one issue is if you have too few hash
tables then you have some error baked
into the into the into your estimates no
matter how many samples you take you're
never gonna get better than whatever
this baked in error is right so you have
to make sure that you have enough hash
tables and then of course you have to
make sure you have enough samples and
these are two different issues so it
turns out the following thing happens if
you compute the minimum probability that
an element of interest falls into your
sampling pool right earlier a sampling
pool was just the bucket of the query
positive that was too small the
probability that an element of interest
falls into that was too small that's why
we needed a lot of hash tables the first
point of expanding the sampling pool is
to increase this probability and so the
number of hash tables that we need is
actually much lower turns out
and now what's the number of samples
that we need well this is a some sort of
data dependent quantity okay so after we
expand our sampling pool now we ask the
question in this sampling pool what's
the expected fraction of elements of
interest right one over that is the
number of samples of evening
so in worst case this could be pretty
bad but you know it just works well in
practice so this is a data dependent
guarantee it's hard to get a worst case
guarantee all right good I'll stop here
I just want to give you a flavor of some
of the ideas it'll involved in all these
different pieces of work and try to
bring out maybe some of the key
differences also interesting
applications of LSH I think anyone's
interesting that you know as I say it
has been around for a long time but
thinking about it as an importance
sampling facilitator has led to new
insights and hopefully some of you will
be motivated to take some of these
deductions even further so thank you so
in interest of time we'll just leave any
further questions that you can ask was
this offline the next at 11:00 and until
everyone free
[Music]